okay guys what's up I have some super
exciting pretty exciting news I don't
know if you know this I'm not only a
BuzzFeed producer I'm also an actor I've
done a some feature films I've done some
TV shows well I know it wasn't me but
I've never done theater in the u.s. I
was actually trained in Russia and did a
lot of theater there but as soon as I
moved here I've only done film and TV so
after going on a couple theater
auditions here in New York I got a phone
call from my manager that's amazing
thank you thank you so much by the way
that was a reenactment I'm an actor so
anyway the reason I'm making this video
is because things got a little
complicated first when I got the part I
was super excited because it was the
lead role in an off-broadway production
in an amazing theater in New York City
called second stage so for the first
rehearsal I was super excited walking
over to the theater because I felt like
a real actor I felt confident I was
ready to crush this show when I showed
up though I realized that the u.s. in my
offer email didn't mean I was doing a US
production it meant I was an understudy
which means that I have to watch the
play over and over and over again until
I fully memorized it and if something
happens to the actual lead I get put on
the second surprise was that as I was
watching the show the kid I'm
understudying Mike Feist gets fully
naked on stage which means I have to get
fully naked on stage so this vlog is
just gonna be me slowly easing myself
into being fully comfortable while fully
nude so the first thing I'm gonna do is
get naked by myself in a studio no one
else is here so I think I should feel
pretty comfortable it's the weirdest
video I've ever done
oh no stop stop stop I mean I I I'm
naked yeah see that okay so I'm
definitely not ready to be naked in
front of people but it might be because
it's like I'm in an office and I don't
want to get fired for like someone
walking in on me naked the other concern
I'm having is hair the hair up here I'm
not allowed to cut that's why I'm
wearing a hat it's crazy but I'm more
concerned about I mean maybe I can get
my whole body wax
oh never mind
I'm never doing that again you know what
this is dumb none of this matters all
that matters is that my acting is good
as long as my acting is good no one's
gonna be thinking about my naked body to
be or not to be honest thing we're
making progress I'm pretty comfortable
acting and being naked it feels good hey
I just wanted your advice the play I'm
doing I have to be fully naked in it I'm
like nervous about it what issues when I
was a little boy I just need someone to
see me naked because then I can get it
over with I can feel like I've shown
somebody my naked body and I can be okay
with it
would you be down to come to a studio
and look at me naked you can't ask
people that would you be down to come
look at me naked
fool me once Eric what pretty please
yeah super male body positivity I will
look at you naked Thank You Clark for
doing this I'm just gonna rip off the
band-aid and go for it so just close
your eyes how do you feel right now very
uncomfortable how do you feel that's
it's important how do you feel honestly
I'm like thankfully you had the reaction
needed I'm finally doing on stage plus
no no no no no you don't get to touch me
but yourself out there like people
people accept it no elbow it baby I'm
gonna go theater now okay so I'm at the
theater and I'm just gonna give a little
tour of the stage we have a little
living room right here kitchen I mean
this is like a real house
the play takes place in 1969 so it looks
a little a little old if you walk up the
stairs and this whole house moves so
it's very terrifying when you're
upstairs we have one room here little
place to read over here then if you open
the door a bedroom so this is the
backstage area this is where we all get
changed between the scenes and stuff
alright so I guess the last thing I can
do to prepare is walk on stage naked
with no audience and see how comfortable
I feel so
[Music]
honestly I feel I feel great I feel free
I feel amazing so I think I'm ready now
I just need to wait for Mike to not show
up and do it okay guys um I just
Mike's usually here like about 30
minutes early every single show and he's
not here the stage manager he told me
that I should be ready to go on I'm
wearing this like microwave weird heat a
bull sweatshirt so that I'm all warm and
you know I don't know what I'm talking
about I'm freaking out but I'm freaking
ready
[Music]
mic mics here so yeah
I'm not getting naked today but you know
there's always tomorrow we still have a
couple weeks left for the show and I'm
Way more comfortable my body now so
that's a plus this was worth it
[Music]